How are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish, new details about the case of
Meissen Domínguez.
According to his lawyer, his mother is already abandoned. She is not
considered a suspect in the investigation.
brand's residence in shows land he is
maldonado's partner and the one who
faces murder charges
maldonado's lawyer says that everyone the cndh
locked him in a room and separated her from
her children for months the lawyer also
indicated that they all read se  seized his
belongings such as cell phone
eliminated any contact with his
friends and family
billy collins appeared
before a judge on friday according to the
metropolitan police collins who is
registered as a sexual abuser is
accused of sexually abusing a
14-year-old boy the incident  It happened
near Lake Maryland when the minor
was on his way to school. Officials
report that he was  they saw him on
surveillance cameras and tracked him down using his
monitor attached to his ankle for a
previous case of thefts the
southern nevada health district is hosting a
kobe drive-thru clinic this
event will be saturday from
9am to 4pm  one in the afternoon at the
winchester cultural center located
about half an hour away and there is already order we have a
complete list of vaccination sites and
detection tests for kobe 19 on
our news now dotcom page in the
Spanish section
and we close the week with cold
temperatures but there will be a nice turn around
very soon we will have a
sunny friday despite temperatures
in the 50s those digits will
slowly climb over the next few days to
the 60 70s and i heard this possibly in
the 80s by the end of next week
im cristian cásseres with your brief
Informative neuro stroke Spanish good
day